normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government I want
to pull up this uh clip from Tucker
Tucker Carlson episode 49 The Dana White
interview how many of you watched this
okay it's basically just an ad for
budlight where Dana White says I'll just
grab a random point at this I'll just
let's just see what happens support
their people like Mexicans support their
people and uh you should be able to walk
in with with with your country's flag so
I brought it back you under pressure not
to allow it there's always you know when
you deal with consider myself a proud
American happy to be an American I love
this country and you are way more
aligned with anheiser bush than you are
with other beer companies that I
guarantee you have you taken any crap
for it listen people are going to say
what they're going to say I I don't ever
I don't care what people I know who I am
I know what I stand for I know what I
believe in and uh the people who are
close to me know and uh I'm on the right
side of this basically the first few
minutes of this 9-minute clip is Dana
White saying everyone should go out and
buy cases and cases of budlight because
they're more aligned with you than you
know and I agree with him I agree with
him I don't know how much he can say to
drive the point home but you have a lot
of people saying no way budlight is dead
to me Etc and you know what I don't
think it matters all that much either
way but I'm on the by Bud Light uh uh
train right now we have Brian kenin says
quote by Bud Light Dana White agrees do
you I think it's silly to judge a
company by one single advertisement
partner they had whether it's the UFC or
Dylan Mulaney just buy products you like
stop trying to cancel every single thing
just because you may may or not 100%
agree with every political ideology they
may have this is one of the greatest
victories you know why the right
boycotted budlight budlight sales tanked
30% budlight desperately tries to win
back the customers they they sponsor
Harley-Davidson doesn't work then they
do a massive deal with UFC and we all
kind of Gran like why we would UFC do
this and then Shan Strickland comes out
and says budlight has now sponsored
everything I have to say and he said
some things I can't repeat on YouTube
because of the censorship but very uh uh
I would say to many people offensive
though many of these people are offended
by everything and that means budlight
switched from underwriting wokeness to
underwriting anti- wokeness there's
nothing more you can ask for I suppose
you could ask for an apology but money
has changed hands and there were people
commenting on the Tucker interview
saying what did budlight do besides
changing money changing hands and I'm
like that's exactly it they're funding a
bunch of based AF MMA fighters now and
UFC and not Dylan Mulaney that's a win
individuals like Conor McGregor who are
also becoming more and more outspoken
politically and might even run to be
president of the United States uh sorry
president of Ireland and so now when
Brian kenin says come on everybody stop
boycotting I say here here when the
Liberals don't boycott budlight but the
conservatives do it creates an inverse
pressure the pressure used to be that
conservatives won't boycott but liberals
will so give the Liberals what they want
cuz conservatives will just roll with
the punches but now that conservatives
are boycotting and the Liberals saying
roll with the punches it's going to
create the inverse pressure system where
now companies are going to push in the
opposite direction and cancel the woke
do they have like a 100 million dollar
contract is what it is so that's that's
a the the company that owns anheiser
bush is a Belgian it's not an American
company I just so you know it's Belgian
it's called AB inbev uh they bought it
it's they're worth 15.5 billion so this
Dro in the bucket of their money I don't
see what you're seeing Tim I I kind of
understand the method specifically yeah
but he's like anheiser bush anheiser
bush is owned by AB inbev which is a
Belgian company he said buy Bud Light
and he was just saying In that clip that
anheiser bush is the best American
company it's the best with you than most
of these other beer compan I don't think
he said it was American um companies are
that I take it from somebody who's in
the know who does business with beer
companies you are way more aligned with
Bud Light than you are
with I mean they didn't come into
partnership with you by accident no
obviously we had multiple bids on the
table they seek you out we had multiple
bids on the table they were one of them
and as I you know history has shown me
with relationships that I've had with
other beer companies I who lean more
this way yeah I who consider myself a
patriot I don't go crazy over the whole
Patriot thing but I consider myself
a proud American I'm happy to be an
American I love this country and you are
way more aligned with anheiser bush than
you are with other beer companies that I
guarantee you you taking any crap for it
listen people are going to say what
they're going to say I I don't ever I
don't care what people I I I don't think
they're an American company no well he's
talking about patriotism there and then
he want to associate it with being
American like that you can definitely
get that Vibe even if he doesn't say
like oh it's an American company mhm he
uses the word Patriot and proud American
and then he sells you on a Belgian
company that has no free speech what we
want is a circumstance in which budlight
loses money when they go woke and they
make money when they go anti-woke so
that every single other company will go
hey guys if we if we sponsor woke people
we're going to lose money but if we
sponsor anti-woke people will make money
if everybody still boycotts budl then it
it's a win either way because then
companies are going to say look don't go
woke cuz you lose money but going
conserve doesn't help you either just
don't go woke wouldn't you consider what
he just did woke like just said I'm a
patriot I'm an American so buy a Belgian
beer that's a like what that's woke as
hell like do your research Dana it's
it's a Belgian beer it's not how's that
help American patriotism to serve the
belgians what he he's encouraging people
to buy us Belgium beer well I'm kind of
split on this because what does that
have to do with anything he used
patriotism to sell people on a foreign
beer yeah it's disingenuous I agree with
you that and I think that it would have
been yeah I mean I I I think he clearly
wanted you to associate this beer with
America with patriotism for America and
so that's disingenuous but I'm split on
the on the idea behind it uh what Tim's
saying because it's like on one hand
it's yeah it's kind of a Pavlov's dog
situation where it's like we want to
train these companies to not be woke and
therefore we should reward them when
they are no longer being woke but at the
same time maybe it takes actually
putting these companies out of business
to send a clear message maybe that was
the end maybe that should be the end
goal rather than just to make them
suffer a little bit I don't know I'm not
saying that like you know I I I I see
both sides of you can't put them out of
business
well I mean anheiser Bush could
subsidize budlight at infinum so the the
best opportunity is to is to give them
the incentive use the carrot not the
stick so then it goes then the the
question then becomes like to what end
would you boycott them like what's the
end goal that would have to be the
decided answer and then I think you know
that you're economic damage which was
30% in sales and then they gave $100
million to UFC and at first we all said
oh grown we don't like Bud Light they
got woke they go broke a lot of people
wanted to go to of business and then
Sean Strickland came out and said a
whole bunch of things on Twitter
laughing saying Bud Light sponsored
thank you this message brought to you by
Bud Light we all laughed and said we
went from Dylan Mulaney and in six
months Shan Strickland right we like
what St Strickland says so we want budl
to fund more of what SE Strickland says
and then we want every other company to
see hey guys if we go with the UFC dudes
we're going to make a lot of money I'm
not going to be happy until there's a
can of Sean strick with
AAG presented to the American people if
they do that then maybe I could give
them a chance personally I don't like
alcohol I don't like booze it it it
calcifies your pineal gland it gives you
Bill Gates Ms that's beyond the point
here does it really calcify your pineal
gland a lot of beer is filled with
fluoride you go okay it's important to
clarify yeah yeah yeah um but but I I I
think the you know I'm kind of like in
the middle here as well cuz I understand
your point I understand your point as
well here how do we kind of move forward
here I would love to have have an
alternative uh company an American
company come out and say hey um we're
we're going to take their we're going to
take their lunch I would rather that
personally myself we have uh Ultra right
conserv conservative dad's Ultra right
beer personally I'm like don't do Seth
weathers is going to be here on the show
uh I don't know I think uh maybe this
week or is he I think it's this week
it's this week and uh and and what he's
doing is fantastic so you know you can
check out his work as well but my point
is just simply it's not about uh
destroying it's like look do you want to
raise the enemy Village or take control
of it to utilize its its labor forces
and resources it depends on the
situation certainly and in this
situation you have you you basically
have a village of people who are all
growing crops bowing down to you saying
please please please we'll give you our
wheat just please stop and instead it's
like you got people saying no no keep
destroying everything that's what they
would do to us they would destroy us I
want I want their resources I want to
take all of their money and put it
towards Sean Strickland and other based
UFC fighters so they can go on Twitter
and say anti-woke things destroying it
doesn't serve a purpose well I um if
you're talking about see in the metaphor
you've got the people and then you have
the resources and the the people are
Traders and they say please please
please let us join you but they're
treacherous then you might want to
remove the humans from that situation to
take the resources for yourself so there
are other times that you actually let
them serve you the resource is the human
capital and labor then you would put
them in slavery or something like that
this is just military talk of course
that you would enslave the population
and make them work for you if you didn't
trust just take taxes from them yeah it
depends on how treacherous they are in
military you conquer a city and you use
its resources towards your military
goals in this in since we're talking
about culture War we can see budlight
destroyed or all of that money they have
can go towards anti-woke initiatives and
then we're actually being armed
culturally against the woken wa I I I
have another Nuance point on this that
might be diverting it a little bit cuz I
brought up Bill Gates moves here and I
just remembered Bill Gates bought a
whole bunch of stocks for aner Bush and
uh therefore Tim I totally disagree with
you I am with with Ian B Bill Bill Gates
buying public stock to try and destroy
the company makes sense to help Bill
Gates and to help wokeness he wants to
make sure no one gets behind the company
and they can't recover for this reason
he's basically saying scorched Earth if
they claim Bud Light then we are going
to lose Resources by buying into it he's
going to get people like you to refuse
to support the company that is funding
UFC anti-woke uh uh personalities I did
some numbers earlier the revenue of
anheiser Bush was 15.5 billion in 2018
15 a half the revenue of its parent
company was 52 billion so 15 52 in 2019
anheiser bush is a skin suit it's not a
real company it's owned by a Belgian
company called anheiser bush 52 billion
in income in Revenue in 2019 so unless
they put like 6 s billion towards this
stuff that we that we like I'm not going
to start to think they really care at
all I think this is a don't think they
care this is just a publicity St of
course and it doesn't matter woke uh uh
leftists have captured the institutions
and the argument from the right is to
sacrifice the institutions instead of
reclaiming them that makes no sense the
goal should be to reclaim and control
all of the cultural institutions so that
we can then indoctrinate young people to
American values um some of the
institutions need to fail I think some
need to read that's what I I think too
that's kind of why I'm in more of like
the let them suffer and like they would
do that to us like they they they want
to destroy us they want to destroy
everything and so if it was like a
patriotic company and this was happening
they'd be like no keep pushing them
don't buy anything from them they made
that's what that's why we're like
whenever they cancel us they have no
forgiveness they have no Grace
whatsoever and it's like why would we
extend that to them don't they need to
them you're like say it's it's like
saying quick burn down our own bridge
that we've reclaimed because they would
have burned it down too why we need the
bridge why not if you're we're going to
build culture why are we just going to
destroy all of what they have built if
we can't just take it for ourselves and
use it ourselves why wouldn't we do that
it makes no sense to get rid of
it Imagine the One Ring you know
budlight is
not budlight is a factory you have woke
forces and anti-woke forces woke forces
have taken over the factory as of the
past few months the anti-woke forces
have reclaimed the servitude of the
factory and now the argument is quick
burn the factory down why we have it
it's ours we get it all because I don't
well a reason why the anti-woke MMA
fighters are getting paid more money UFC
is getting funded this means the public
will recognize the statements made by
these Fighters are funded by Bud Light
you have lost this cultural battle
except if the factory if you're like now
that's our Factory but who is in that
factory running that factory and who are
their financial ties behind the scenes
that I don't know so if I really want to
leave that factory up and running what's
the risk thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net